the last thing I ever want to do is
shoot you I'm definitely going to beat
your ass up but I don't want to have to
shoot you in one time I didn't feel like
fighting this month
[Laughter]
yeah I was like look bro I'm not in the
mood right now
I'm gonna shoot you in your foot
he kept talking I pulled that big [__]
out like I said he got look like they
came from the aliens where are you
hiding if it has the big circles
like I've been from his angle I look
like CJ I'm San Andreas
I forgot who I was talking to about it
oh it hadn't been somebody in Cali
because he was like I feel like
Thunder's gonna be good here you know
because I'm telling them Texas we got he
was like yeah I feel like it's gonna be
good because uh
this might die but it's okay because
because you have to have examples just
clip that right there might die but it's
okay for real